foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be covering the weirdest
theories ranking them all the way up to
the weirdest theory of all I've covered
a few of these in the channel in the
past but there are also some new ones
these are going to be explained fairly
succinctly but if you want the full
version of one of these theories you can
find it on the Channel's homepage which
weird Harry Potter theories do you guys
know do you think you can guess them
without further Ado let's get started
number five George Weasley is Willy
Wonka this extremely weird Theory
connects the Harry Potter Universe
written by JK Rowling with the universe
of Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
another fictional tale written by Roald
Dahl however this audacious Theory
certainly doesn't just Loosely connect
the Two Worlds it actually suggests that
George Weasley AIDS at Willy Wonka the
theory put quite succinctly suggests
that George Weasley after suffering the
loss of his brother Fred uses a Time
Turner to travel back to a different era
making a new life for himself as we know
George and Fred were the closest of
Brothers spending every waking moment
with one another however when Fred
tragically passed away George was at a
bit of a loss for what to do next
Rowling even addressed the issue herself
tragically remarking that George would
never get over losing Fred with his
business Acumen having successfully run
Weasley's Wizarding wheezers and fast
knowledge of sweets George travels back
in time and starts a new life in the
land of the Muggles opening Willy
Wonka's chocolate factory sharing his
wacky inventions and tasty sweets with
the Muggle world to add to all of this
George even appears to resemble Willy
Wonka somewhat this theory is a stretch
and I'm not convinced but it's
definitely a fun idea and a weird one at
that but before we dive in any further
I've got a word from today's sponsor
wonder is an app that allows you to turn
words into digital art using their
software your imagination and just a few
word prompts you can turn your your
artistic Visions into a real piece of
digital artwork all you need to do is
enter a prompt pick an art style and hit
create from here you can watch Wonder
bring your idea to life I like using it
to frame my favorite characters and
places from Harry Potter in a new light
here's Hogwarts School underwater using
the Cinematic art style here's Voldemort
mixed with Dumbledore using the magic
art style here's Hagrid doing ballet in
the Forbidden Forest using the
novelistic art style here's Hogwarts
burning to the ground using the
novelistic art style and his Severus
Snape drinking a margarita on the beach
if you need to bring an idea to life
Wonder can probably do it if this
interests you click the link in the
description box below for a free trial
the trial of the premium version
includes unlimited art no ads faster
load times and over 20 styles to choose
from so again if you want to give Wonder
a go click the link in the description
box below and get started with your free
trial back to the video
4. Mrs Norris is filcher's wife this
Theory discusses Argus filch Hogwarts
caretaker and Resident Squibb as well as
his trusty feline companion Mrs Norris
now in the Harry Potter story it's made
quite clear that Argus filch doesn't
love a lot of things makes the lives of
the student body miserable and exacts
what little power he has at every
opportunity however if there's one thing
he does love it's certainly his cat Mrs
Norris a dust-colored feline with
piercing yellow eyes the two are never
apart except for when they've
temporarily decided to scout out
different areas of the school and they
seem to have an almost quasi-telepathic
connection as they're able to
communicate in spite of the fact that
they are just well squib and Cat when
Mrs Norris encounters students
misbehaving filch seems to show up right
away and vice versa so what could be the
explanation for their complicated
relationship in 1992 when Mrs Norris was
petrified by Salazar slytherin's
basilisk filch first blamed Harry Potter
who was spotted right at the scene of
the crime filch is visibly more upset
than we've ever seen him before and says
in front of everyone you killed my cat
I'll kill you I'll kill you while filch
is bitter and a bit hard to deal with
sometimes he's not usually so violent in
nature and is passionate he's exhibiting
to me suggests that perhaps he knows Mrs
Norris on a deeper level perhaps he
knows something about her but the rest
of us don't the theory suggests this Mrs
Norris is filter's wife but how could a
cat be his wife well the simple answer
to that is that she's a maledictus that
is the sufferer of a blood curse which
caused her to gradually and eventually
turn in to a cat this would of course
mean that Mrs Norris was once a woman
and not just any woman filcha's wife
again this theory is a bit of a stretch
and a weird one but it certainly caught
my attention three Ron is Dumbledore yep
you heard that right the basis for this
Harry Potter fan theory is that Ron
Weasley Harry his best friend is in fact
a time traveling version of Hogwarts
Headmaster Alba stumbledore the primary
Arguments for this Theory and there are
quite a few are that Dumbledore seems to
know everything that Harry and Ron did
and they're about to do Ron and
Dumbledore purportedly share some
physical similarities both being
described as tall then possessing a long
nose that has been broken a few times
and large hands Dumbledore also had red
hair as a boy which we know because of
Tom Riddle's memory Dumbledore has a
scar above his left knee and Ron
received an injury to his left leg
possibly knee area both men are obsessed
with sweets and introductions to both
characters involve sweets Dumbledore
sees himself holding socks in the
miravera said which relates to Ron
Weasley not appreciating Mrs Weasley's
Christmas socks however one of the main
drivers behind the theory relates to the
Philosopher's Stone particularly the
chess match that Ron participates in in
order to allow Harry to move on to the
next challenge the argument here is that
the chess match is symbolic for the war
between good and evil in the series with
Iran being representative of the night
supporting Harry and Dumbledore acting
as king controlling everything Voldemort
was able to save his memory in Tom
Riddle's Diary and was able to come back
to the real world through it so why
couldn't Dumbledore achieve something
similar I'm not convinced that this
theory has much Merit but it's certainly
a weird one two rolling is Rita Skeeter
Rita Skeeter was a British witch an
Infamous journalist in the Harry Potter
story who specialized in writing
defamation pieces for the daily Prophet
she was known for her poison pen stories
which she would based around false
information and misreported interviews
writing what she believed people would
like to read whether it was real
information or not this Theory put quite
simply is simply that Rita Skeeter and
JK Rowling are one in the same after
being fired from the ministry for being
an unregistered animagus a beetle
mosquito escapes to the Muggle world
where she publishes her stories as
fictional Works eventually adopting the
pseudonym JK Rowling I like this one
number one Dudley and Cho Theory and
last but certainly not least the
weirdest theory on a list the chuddly
theory that is the theory that Dudley
does the ended up marrying Ravenclaw
graduate Cho Chang this Theory came
about for a couple of reasons but the
main driver behind it is that Cho Chang
ended up marrying a muggle that's Canon
Cho Chang married a muggle furthermore
we also know that Dudley dursley ends up
getting married himself but the name of
his wife is never revealed this is
basically the entire basis for the
theory an unnamed wife and an unnamed
muggle we know Dudley dursley is a
muggle and while it's unusual for
witches and wizards to marry Muggles it
definitely still happens often when a
witch or wizard is courting a potential
muggle spouse they fail to mention their
magical abilities which causes tension
down the line when their kids start
performing magic themselves the guilt
eventually becomes unbearable and they
end up confessing their magical status
to their other half however the years of
lies are not often entirely understood
so in this respect the relationship
between Cho and Dudley does sort of make
sense if Cho were to have married a
regular muggle then she would have no
doubt encountered the aforementioned
difficulties associated with Muckle
courtship however if she were to end up
with Dudley it was a muggle that is the
obvious advantage that she would never
have to hide anything from him Dudley
was privy to the magical world and there
wouldn't have been much that Cho could
have said to put him off or surprise him
okay now I know what you're thinking Cho
and Dudley Dudley was about as awful as
a young boy could be however there was a
point in Dudley's life at which he hit a
bit of a Crossroads lead to Mentor
attack though the Dementors weren't able
to successfully suck out Dudley's Soul
the attack still had a profound impact
on him as it forced him to observe the
type of person that he was after the
attack Dudley certainly changed for the
better and Cho well I can definitely see
her vacating the Wizarding World
entirely after the death of Cedric
wanting an escape from The Madness of it
all what do you think is chudley Cannon
and that's it for this video had you
guys heard of these theories were there
weirdest theories out there that I
missed how would you rank them leave a
comment down below until next time it
does not do to dwell on dreams forget to
live